[موسيقى]
في
الثاني من يونيو بالرياض ، ستعقد المملكة
العربية السعودية والأمم المتحدة
مؤتمر
تعهدات لليمن ، إن المفوضية السامية للأمم المتحدة لشؤون اللاجئين مقتنعة
بأن المجتمع الدولي
سيستمر في إظهار تضامنه مع تلك
العائلات اليمنية
النازحة وأولئك اللاجئين الذين
ليسوا كذلك.  حان الوقت للتخلي عن اليمن ، حيث
لا يمكنهم
مواجهة فيروس الشريان التاجي بمفردهم
، لا يمكنهم مواجهة
خمس سنوات من الصراع بمفردهم ، نحن
المجتمع الإنساني على استعداد
للمساعدة ولكننا بحاجة إلى
دعم مالي من
المجتمع الدولي لن يكون العالم آمنًا بما في ذلك
منه  فيروس كورونا
إذا تخلينا عن اليمنيين لمصيرهم الآن
أكثر من 280000 لاجئ معظمهم من
الصومال
لديهم تمويل للجوء في اليمن ،
كما تحمي وكالة اللاجئين التابعة للأمم المتحدة وتساعد
بعض العائلات اليمنية الأكثر ضعفاً
التي فرت خمس سنوات من الصراع
الذي
نواجهه  رعاية 3.6 مليون
يمني دمر منزلهم ويعيشون الآن
في منطقة مجاورة فقيرة جدًا  حي
عدن وسنا جنبًا إلى جنب مع اللاجئين ، تعيش
بعض تلك العائلات اليمنية النازحة
أيضًا في
موقع مضيف مزدحم قريب من
المراكز الحضرية في حالة مزرية للغاية حيث
يكاد يكون الوصول الكافي للمياه أمرًا مستحيلًا حيث يكون العزلة الذاتية
أو المسافات المادية
شبه
مستحيلة وحيث يكون الاجتماع  إن احتياجاتهم اليومية
هي في الحقيقة صراع لكل من
اللاجئين
والعائلات النازحة داخليًا
[الموسيقى]
ينظر السكان إلى كل من اللاجئين والعائلات اليمنية التي نزحت بسبب النزاع
على
أنها ناقل محتمل لـ
kovid 19. وبالتالي فإن مفوضية الأمم المتحدة للاجئين
لديها بالفعل  تلقى
تقريرًا عن التمييز والمضايقات ،
فهم أول من يفقد وظيفته
بسبب تباطؤ
الاقتصاد ،
فهم أول من يُحرم من
الوصول إلى
الرعاية الطبية لأنه يُنظر إليهم على أنهم
قد يجلبون
فيروس الزاوية إلى المجتمعات
اليمنية.  تمتلك وكالة اللاجئين التابعة للأمم المتحدة
الأدوات والوسائل
لفعل المزيد لكلا اللجوء  es والأسر
النازحة داخليًا ،
يمكننا القيام
بالمزيد من توزيع أطفال النظافة ،
يمكننا توفير المزيد من النقود للعائلات
التي تفقد مصدر رزقها أو
مقيدة في حركتها من
أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة والاستمرار في شراء
الطعام أو الدواء
لعائلاتهم للأسف
لم نتلق حتى
ثلث التمويل المطلوب
لمساعدة 280000 لاجئ
وبعض 3.6 مليون
أسرة يمنية نزحت بسبب
النزاع
إذا تلقينا ما
يقرب من 35 مليونًا ،
فسنكون قادرين على مساعدة أكثر من 70
ألف عائلة نازحة كلاهما لاجئ.
العائلات اليمنية النازحة بسبب
النزاع بالنقود الأساسية التي ستسمح لهم خلال الطمع
بالبقاء على قيد الحياة في الشهرين أو الثلاثة أشهر
القادمة للحد من حركتهم لعزل
أنفسهم إذا
مرض أحد أفراد الأسرة
للتغلب على فقدان الوظائف
والقدرة على الشراء  بعض الأطعمة
والأدوية التي ستكون أه
حرجة للغاية خلال هذه
الفترة أه القادمة أمام القبطية 19.
[موسيقى]
ذ  ou